[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Rachel in Missouri
she says I've been listening to you for
over 20 years and I'm so grateful for
your financial principles my family is
close to paying off for a mortgage and
then we are completely debt free will
you please give perspective on our world
events talking about the Israel at War
Etc what's the best advice to prepare
financially for our own home and how to
invest with so much turmoil this is an
interesting question Dave I'll give my
uh two cents on this I'd love to hear
your side of this um Rachel things like
this whenever there's Calamity whenever
there's uncertainty in the world I think
about coid and all those things uh I
really go quickly to controlling what I
can control and in this case like you
said you're close to paying off your
mortgage you're close to being
completely debt free do those things
that you know to do and continue walking
down that path and um and then for me I
just also have to accept it's like in
one hand I control the things that I can
control and then on the other hand I
have to accept the things that I can't
control and one thing that I have found
that helps me accept the things I can't
control is I tend to want to lean into
generosity a little bit and then there's
kind of just like okay I can't go
overseas and I may not be the one that
can save people but I can be generous in
my community there's things that I can
still do so that's the way that I would
approach that
um and that are those are the two things
that have given me peace uh in times
like these what about you Dave now that
makes a lot of sense um control the
controllables I mean when we were in the
fouchy pandemic you know we didn't know
what was going to happen um you know it
was we'd never been in a fouy pandemic
before you didn't know what to do right
and so um you know you just kind of got
to get in there and wind your way
through that one actually showed up in
Missouri I don't think Hamas is going to
show up in Missouri I could be wrong but
I'm prettyy pretty sure of that one um
might be wrong I mean sure as I say that
it'll be tomorrow but I I don't think so
I think you're I think you're probably
okay but then the question is what does
world what do Global events do to your
Investments well if you're invest in the
stock market for instance in your 401k
sometimes Global events temporarily
affect that uh a a scare in the Ukraine
a scare um in Israel a war in Israel a
war in the Ukraine uh can affect uh
stock market usually fairly
temporarily um certainly an event in the
Homeland an event in the United States
proper would affect the stock market but
even 911 when the towers were uh
attacked by those cowards um and they
you know they they fell and they fell if
you don't know literally within blocks
of Wall Street the actual New York Stock
Exchange is right there okay you
couldn't get to it for a day or two
because of the rubble and so but also we
traditionally shut down the stock market
exchange the New York Stock Exchange and
for that matter the uh the NASDAQ which
is in Chicago will shut down trading
during during horrible events like an
attack on American soil uh we shut it
down well it so it shut down the 911 was
on a Tuesday stock market didn't reopen
until Monday and as soon as it reopened
you know what it did
Dove 500 points in a matter of
moments you know what it did and then it
went down like for a week it just kept
going down and everybody's like oh the
they they' they've crash they've crashed
the towers and they crashed the American
economy no not even close I kept telling
people look buy buy buy it's time to buy
it's going down buy it's on sale byy I
don't want to take advantage of a
Calamity that's not the point but the
Market's gone down this is not the time
to sell it's the time to to buy because
54 days later it returned to where it
was which nobody talked about and never
made a single news headline but the news
headline big bold across the front page
of the the you know the local uh liberal
pamphlet we have that's called a
newspaper and um big bold big bold
letter stock market crashes following
terrorist attack you know how much
coverage they gave it when 54 days later
it completely returned zero not one
mention not one anywhere even CNBC which
is supposed to report on business didn't
report it even Fox Business didn't
report it because Fox Business was not
in existence then so there and you know
but there you go that's what that's how
this world event things work so what you
do is you keep buying so Dave you all
the time you just keep buying the rest
of your life you keep buying until it's
time for you to sell you do not buy or
sell based on world events because they
always have a temporary impact so we
always say here that when you're
investing you're spreading it over four
types right growth growth and income
aggressive growth International and I
feel like I've heard you say
International is kind of like the Wild
Child right no it's the weak spot that's
the weak spot and that is because those
economies have not done as well right
and we know that overall in the United
States foreign stocks as a category have
not kept up with us stocks as a category
but there's a reason for for the last 40
years there's a reason that it's still a
quarter of the strategy exactly because
there are times that things like a BMW
or a Mercedes were they still owned by
Germans they're not now but you know
were they you know think of a foreign
company then there's a bunch of them
that you ingest and do business with
every day and don't think anything about
it um but their stock then is a
considered a foreign stock and so
there's times that they're going to
prosper sometimes on the back of the US
economy that's true but there's still
that that profit is from a foreign goes
to a foreign company then so uh it's not
a patriotic issue it's a math thing and
so um you just keep investing you just
keep investing Rachel and I got to tell
you if you're worried about a paid for
house in
Missouri because of the war in Israel
you need to turn the television off yeah
that's true you're watching it too much
because that you your reality is getting
distorted um as to what's what the real
effect is going to be on your life no
one is happy about Israel being attacked
well some people are happy but I mean n
none of the people around me are people
like me are happy about it we're all in
horri horrified with what's going on
it's absolute evil but um but from a
financial or economic
perspective year from now it'll be a
distant memory from a political
perspective 10 years from now it'll be a
history note in a book that's all it'll
be just a note that's true like the 1967
1972 same same dates at Israel right
same thing just a note in the history
book yeah and so but while you're living
in it it's a real thing and so but you
can't get caught up in things that are
happening somewhere else control the
controllables yeah it's tough I think um
the way the world is there's social
media there's 24hour a day Network news
right and it's constantly feeding us the
worst possible things happening in
society and if we don't put boundaries
around that we will destroy our brains
like we will we will be in fear 247 yeah
it's a 24/7 news cycle 47 fear cycle is
fear porn and that you know not to say
that the Israel thing is not real uh is
obviously real it's obviously horod it's
a tragedy it's a disaster yeah it's all
of those things but um but it but is it
going to affect Rachel in Missouri no no
other than pray for I was going to say
Pray for Peace in Jerusalem yep other
than the way that we can Compass that's
all you can do hey thank you thank you
for your question Rachel open phones
atle 8825
55225 um by the way there's lots of
information on the stock market history
that is very intriguing when you dig
into it one piece of information I saw
in one of the brochures one time is if
you had invested at the worst possible
day in the stock market in the last five
years and you did that every five years
M you would have so much money the worst
possible day yeah CU you were buying at
the bottom yeah cheap you know and you
say okay this is the horrible thing that
happened right after 911 if you had
invested right if you had invested after
you know Black Monday in 1987 if you'd
which Market just Dove like 20% in one
day was crazy it's a weird day if you'd
invested on the worst possible days if
You' invested at the highest possible
days how much money you'd have and it's
still a lot of money something so the
point of the chart or the illustration
is keep investing keep investing keep
investing the only people that get hurt
on a roller coaster are those that jump
off in the middle of the ride